[Applause]
yeah thank you all right settle down
there fellas
he loved me like 10 minutes ago and i
then you come out and like conan who
i did my foot turn you on my naked foot
just be honest
yes
you've answered the question all i do is
imagine what goes up from that foot
which might look similar
and
it makes you really want to take you to
a spot yeah yeah yeah i need a spa don't
i i need a spa i don't go to spas i
don't like the terry cloth robes and the
no oils
you don't need that see um if you come
to la i really want you if you ever come
to la i want to take you to
some spas in koreatown and have like a
fat korean woman to scrub you down it's
none of this fancy schmancy stuff you
just you just
oh wow it sounds so tempting
a back korean woman will scrape what is
she scraping all over my body um she
basically like takes i don't know if any
of you guys have ever done this it's
great it's fantastic really i recommend
it basically takes kind of like a like a
brillo pad and it just scrapes you down
and but it's it's really good for you so
it's sort of masochistic it's sort of
what they use to get grease and grime
off a pot is dragged over your skin by a
very powerful woman yes wow doesn't that
take me my flesh would just come off i
would just i'd come out like a skeleton
wow that was really nice i'm glad i did
that yeah i think that'd be nice because
i just actually want to see how much
comes off of you
that sounds gross i'm moving on
uh thanks very much for being here first
of all and congratulations uh grey's
anatomy this thing's a huge hit you got
to be
excited i've always thought
and i guess in preparation for the role
of of of playing uh you know medical
professional you decided to sit through
some surgery some real surgeries is that
true yes it's fantastic uh we had
so much research and and so much help
from a lot of the local hospitals that
you could feel that you really
understood what was going on so what
kind of procedure did you did you sit
down and on a heart replacement valve
surgery a valve replacement so you were
there i was there so it's it's fantastic
one the woman was you know she was very
generous to let myself katherine heigl
and actually two design students they
were a design engineer right uh guys and
who were observing and uh you're
literally this far away from her head
right yeah from the entire field so you
got the permission first because you
don't want the woman coming out of
surgery and this is your doctor and this
is the actor
we just wanted to look at your insides
no no she gave us a permission and we
went in and it's just i was very very
nervous of course you can be sure you
don't know what it is and all those you
know medical surgery shows and all that
stuff you think it's going to be really
really gross
and i was kind of queasy you know before
right so i was wondering am i going to
throw up am i going to faint right but i
got to tell you man it was just
what a rush i really get i really get it
because you have life really in front of
you and like when you know you have to
open up the the chest with the saw and
stuff and i you just think that you're
going to be grossed out but at least i
wasn't yeah you don't want to go too far
the other way and be like yeah you know
no but what what what you whoo
is that it
cracked your chest dude but it can
really give you it really gives you a
rush right
at that point you're not thinking about
whether you're feeling queasy or not
it's extremely exciting do you always uh
do this for roles if you're playing a
part you you try and go and study people
that actually do that too i'd like to
whenever i can you know there are
various projects that i've done that you
know you you really get uh get into
their world sure sure like what what was
another example of a time that you you
studied something before you you
portrayed that role
uh
various things uh
let's see like
right now i you know with this play i'm
doing called satellites it's about you
know a woman who is newly married and
has a baby although that has not
happened to me
um basically i'm doing a portrayal of my
sister
and my best friend all combined so it's
like spending time with them or like you
know what i've i've you know had to be
pregnant in a lot of things where you
spend time with your friends who are
pregnant and also other things like you
know i've played a variety of characters
and one
one a really actually great experience
was this film called dancing at the blue
iguana and that happened to be about um
these five strippers in l.a so i'm like
from a pretty conservative background i
had never ever been in a strip club
before the day of the audition me either
to this day
[Laughter]
i saw that yeah i saw that no no
but uh but with that uh that process we
did
which with the film was improvised we
spent all this time in strip clubs and
and we that's how we learned how to
dance and really did you get up on stage
then in front of people i got to tell
you man there's so many so many clubs in
l.a that i have dance and no one has no
one's known yeah right right yeah
because usually we kind of went there
like before it would open so it would
like be very very slow and you know no
one would really was it i mean it must
be in some way liberating you know to do
something like that oh i think so like
actually sheila kelly who was a um
one of the cast members she's kind of
made this empire right of teaching women
how to pull dance and i i gotta tell you
for all the women out there i really
really highly recommend it because it is
exciting
you know
and of course there are a lot of guys
that are out there because it's like you
know if you because
it's also beneficial to you if you know
your partner is learning to liberate
herself sex i think it's good for
everyone if women are pole dancing
but through their own means through
their own means yes
you